Thierry tu m'excites quand tu quand tu
dis ton Serge
on va faire un jeu on va jouer au jeu tu
vas finir mes phrases d'accord interview
finir mes phrases
[Applaudissements]
attention alors bouder rire c'est un bon
moyen de communication oui je dois tout
à Dieu j'ai grandi entouré de entouré de
cafards
[Rires]
c'est la première fois je suis entouré
autant de belles filles
la nature m'a bien gâté au niveau de
de mon nez oui j'ai un bonnet c'est vrai
pour 2006 j'ai décidé d'arrêter
j'ai décidé d'arrêter d'être Aurélie
[Rires]
pour me détendre je fais beaucoup de
pour me détendre Philippe tu fais quoi
pour te détendre du golf pour me
détendre
la France c'est le pays
le pays
c'est le pays de moi
je suis fan de je suis fan de Dorothée
c'est dans une sandwicherie ouais j'ai
payé un sandwich il y avait rien dedans
la force de Le Pen c'est il a qu'un œil
il est trop fort avec un œil
[Rires]
avec un œil il voit tout c'est chaud
j'ai jamais dit ça à personne mais
Laurent Baffie tu es un diable
j'étais voir tous ces trucs
[Applaudissements]
j'aimerais bien avoir une plus grosse
montre parce que j'en ai pas
Thierry tu m'excites quand tu quand tu
dis Molly ton Serge
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu